in this video i'm going to break down
exactly how the [ __ ] a 70 000 tesla can
cost less than a standard 40 000
combustion engine car
over
9.9 years of ownership 1.9 years david
that's dumb time frame why not 10 years
well 9.9 years is the average ownership
of a vehicle across the entire globe
back to the point how is 70 000 less
than 40 000 well let's break it down
across these five different points we're
going to be looking at fuel
licensing insurance tires and schedule
maintenance across the life cycle of
owning a car there's no in this video so
we're going to break it down step by
step in the most comparable way as
quickly as we possibly can starting with
fuel fuel is the most obvious one when
you're comparing an electric vehicle to
a petrol powered or diesel vehicle first
of all if you're traveling approximately
20 000 kilometers per year you're
probably going to spend about 2
800 a year on fuel alone that's assuming
an average of 6.5 liters per 100
kilometers in your standard vehicle
whereas if you were to charge an
electric vehicle in western australia
during off-peak rates 20 000 kilometers
worth of recharge miles would actually
only cost you five hundred and fifty
dollars so that's a saving of two
thousand two hundred and fifty dollars
every single year by simply owning a
tesla over a typical car the next
category is licensing and this may be
different in your state so please check
your regulations however in western
australia licensing is based on the
actual weight of your vehicle so if you
compare a tesla model 3 or a tesla model
y to a typical sedan they're much for
muchness in weight so your licensing
every single year is exactly the same
which means no savings for the tesla and
no savings for the petrol car now we're
going to break down insurances insurance
is a pretty obvious one
your tesla is now costing you 420
dollars more to insure every single year
than your 40 000 petrol car but we're
not done yet and this is where it
actually gets interesting if we start
looking at tires for example i'll give
you my personal case i drive a mercedes
a-class which runs four run flat tires
across the board each tire costs me 300
apiece every two years i need to replace
the full set so on average we can assume
two tires once a year at 600 australian
dollars whereas on a tesla teslas don't
run run flats even though this is a huge
con it does bring the price of tyres
down we're talking 235
attire using the same comparison we're
saving money once again now this is
where it really adds up and this is
where it really makes it worth your
while considering the numbers and
breaking it down
a standard service for a mercedes-benz
here in australia is anywhere from
thirteen hundred to fifteen hundred
dollars every single 12 months which
means if you average it out at 1400 for
a service it gets pretty rough whereas
the tesla model 3 tesla model y or any
tesla that you select has no standard
servicing straight off the bat we're
saving 14 hundred dollars by simply
switching to electric now the following
are averages for my personal situation
and they're broken down across the
lifespan of every replacement required
for each part so it is 94 per year on
air filters it's 179 a year on spark
plugs 171
on average for the main battery
replacement 285 dollars a year for brake
pads 220 a year for brake fluid which
means i'm spending 2
349
a year to service a mercedes benz why
don't you take it to a local mechanic
david they'll charge you half the price
yes i know but i need to do this
comparison like for like it needs to be
the tesla dealership versus the
mercedes-benz dealership so it is a fair
even comparison now the tesla model 3
and the tesla model y are identical for
servicing and scheduled maintenance so
this is where you will be sold instantly
schedule servicing zero air filters
fifty dollars per year spark plugs zero
main battery replacement hopefully zero
forty two dollars a year on brake pads
fifty dollars a year on brake fluids
meaning you're spending 142
on servicing and maintaining your
vehicle every single year so now let's
look at the grand total if you were to
go out and purchase a 40 000 mercedes
benz and own it for 9.9 years it would
cost you 113
745
and 10 cents to own that vehicle
that is a huge
number considering you're literally
spending one third of that on the actual
car itself now i did promise you that
the tesla was cheaper over 9.9 years of
ownership the tesla model 3 or the tesla
model y
will cost you 102
491
and 80 cents to own and that's it i'm
david thomach i'll see you next time